guys are just wishing that a woman just
gives them a little bit of attention
right they pay for it they do anything
for it strip CL Only You Name It guys
are hooked on this fitna of women and
women know that they can leverage that
power that seduction against men and men
are they used to be strong before or
they used to be like forget you I'm
going somewhere else I got options to
now like please give me one look please
give me one shout out on your only chat
so that I can be happy and go pmo in
peace you know there was a guy who
bought some only fans models
bathwater yeah bathwater bro he paid
right I think 10 or 100,000 to get
shipped a little bottle of bath water is
this what loser sorry the sahaba died
for this they died for men to be who
they are and come back to Allah and this
is what men are doing
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the the three Muslims minus two Muslims
plus one Muslim over here alhamdulillah
we are joined here with our
esteemed jel alomani bro my guy how long
has it been now since we've uh seen each
other been over a year over a year
alhamdulillah time flies so for anybody
that is not familiar with your work
right now tell them a little bit about
yourself and your Weaver Journey
bro
ald good to see one of the three Muslims
again after while it's actually over a
year and what three months four months
alhamdulillah time passes by fast like
life yeah so uh I basically work um as a
positive psychology counselor and I
counsel people of all backs of Life all
backgrounds alhamdulillah with regards
to manhood masculinity marriage issues
you name it everything that's uh real
life real problems real solutions
alhamdulillah not been a revert or
convert it's been almost man 20 years
now Subhan Allah what year did you
convert so it was
three okay so 20 yeah 20 years going to
going to like the years November right
now yeah what's the what's the main like
cliff notes to your rever story Subhan
Allah my friend Kamal the Bosnian he
just did a at our old high
school just today right now you sent me
the video really yeah so he was first H
by at our high school because now they
did like high school program and he was
talking about I think he entitled like
the happiest day of my life because
supposedly that was his happiest day
when I converted to Islam so just as a
summary like do da man don't belittle da
whatever da it is whatever you can as
the prophet sallam
said
convey even if it's one a that's what
the brother did you know whatever he
knew he told me and Subhan Allah you
know I I embrac Islam some time after I
mean it wasn't like right away right you
plant that seed and then it comes back
so when we started da was
1998 that's when he started doing da to
me I became Muslim 2003 that's five
years
alhamdulillah but um that's all I can
say never belittle da whatever it is a
book a pamphlet a website a video
whatever it is you don't know when that
person is going to Islam is going to
enter their hearts and you used to be a
Subhan Allah Catholic or
Christian yeah it's a complicated story
but it was a mix of things so family
part of them were Catholics some
Orthodox some were unitarians so it was
a mix of things I grew up in a you can
say the main umbrella was Christianity
yes alhamdulillah so this being said
when our brother Andrew Tate reverted
last year I believe before he got locked
up what was your initial reaction to
that
so
obviously you know we're happy for
anyone who comes to Islam and Andrew
always reminds me just of some of the I
don't want to compare him to sahab
obviously because a lot of people get
sensitive right because obviously
there's nothing like sahab because Allah
says
like he actually seals their character
that Allah is pleased with them as for
us may Allah any guide us and help us to
to become better right so we don't know
where we stand but we know where they
stand where the saaba stood so with
Andrew obviously I was happy because no
matter what even before Islam I
criticized him in a few videos right and
that's the way it is we don't follow
people based on how popular they are or
how their Charisma or anything like that
we follow them on how they follow Islam
and that's always my message to everyone
even like to myself if I make some
mistakes like don't follow me because
you like me you know I don't like you
people say oh yeah M this and that but
then what if I do something wrong and
then you're like yeah okay Mah I'm still
with you you know it's like groupy
mentality so I was happy at the same
time I'm hopeful that he fixes some
things because he's in the spotlight and
he's got an amazing
opportunity just an amazing like if he
can hear me right now we're trying to
reach out to him so we can go actually
Edie and I were planning to go visit him
soon you know oh I hope we can get to
him because see he's in a spot right now
that if he just tweaks things a bit I
know like look he's not gonna be like
okay anim or something like that right
people shouldn't treat him like that but
if he just tweaks a few things with his
influence I think he can do some amazing
amazing thing the world is watching he
has been the voice for many young men
it's the same thing that we've been
echoing obviously he's Allah blessed him
to have that traction okay people listen
to him he's somehow he blew up
online some people have been talking
about this topic for many many years
before they didn't this Allah's y way of
of raising people or whatever this is
Allah's way that's it but he needs to
understand this great opportunity even
the non-muslims are going to be
influenced
imagine Malcolm X okay Malcolm X if you
think about him his background so again
I don't want people to to because you
know people are very sorry an very
feminine very reactionary right you say
something like brother how dare you how
can you say that how can you compare him
to sahaba so I'm not comparing sa how
can you you comparing to Malcolm X I'm
not comparing to X but I just want you
to understand so Malcolm X was you know
it's coming from a ghetto background
right uh gangster he was in ja Islam
yeah yeah he was in jail for first he
was in jail then obviously Nation of
Islam but look at his change and his
activism so he was a gangster he was
okay for lack of better words but he was
in jail and so his change though was a
very systematic yet very ethical and
academic change right till today he
influences so many people so he's he's
coming from that back I mean Malcolm X
was was a man no doubt he was a man all
right he was he was a real man like if
you talking about masculinity definitely
was a man okay it was none of these
poofs that you see today right he was a
man so when he talks we talk about
masculinity manhood 100% but see see he
he was very careful to not allow his his
background to stain when he started
representing Islam and how did he do
that how did he ensure that I think he
did that first of all through knowledge
seeking
knowledge uh he was getting a lot of
feedback and help and he was searching
for that like he was always open for
people to advise him and to he was very
keen on learning which I'm not sure
again I don't know with Andrew but I
don't know if from what I understand
he's not doesn't have enough advisers I
don't know if he's not allowing people
or if he's just kind of like aware or
scared or based on what's been happening
but I don't think he has a lot of
advisors or teachers let's say even more
so he needs teachers and instead of
people let's say just talking bad about
him I think more people should focus on
reaching him to become teachers for him
yeah so we we went to Dubai a couple
times and spent time with his friend
juwel right uh so told your shooter and
you know the times that we spent with
him al man he's really excelling after
reverting and a lot of people have
brought up this point that oh you know
we just wish Andrew Tate would be on
Dean too and I don't understand why
people don't realize that not even a
month I believe after he reverted he got
locked up right how are you going to
study the dean when you're in a Romanian
jail cell with cockroaches bro cold you
just got hot water once a day and it's
insane bro like you you expect we're
living in like the best roofs under the
best roofs money can buy air
conditioning life is good we have
everything at our fingertips and yet
we're lazy we're addicted to watching
videos relapsing on nofap yet we're
criticizing quick to criticize our
brother who's locked up and he can't
even you know learn the dean now he has
time but he's a Reaver right and and
your yourself being a Reaver yourself do
you think that it took time or was it in
time it took time it was just uh like
hopefully the hunger is there you know
what I mean I think that needs to be
there definitely to push back a little
bit on that a lot of the brothers who
came out of jail right now recently was
a rapper that came out of after five
years can't remember his name right but
I saw this nice picture of him praying
in the hood was a bunch of Brothers
behind him like he was leading Jama you
know it's a famous rapper uh he was
locked up for about five years so
definitely you can you know and I think
Andrew did he like this one thing he did
he stud he was reading the Quran in jail
and that's nice and some Hadith and he
was even tweeting that so that's good I
just hope I want actually for him if he
hears this if you guys can obviously get
the M him to just recognize the
responsibility that is on him just for
the fact that he converted to Islam a
lot of people might say that no no no
but keep in mind people are looking at
you there's no way they're going to
dissociate Islam from you right now
right you know like how when Dave
Chappelle was asking are you a Muslim
he's like yeah but I'm not not good at
it so it's like okay but keep in mind
that people are going to right they're
going to look at you and a lot of people
today because we live it's not because
humans are bad or anything but we live
in a very shall shallow world is very
superficial so we do tend to
prefer and be attached to personalities
because we've been conditioned like that
movies social media we're conditioned
and as human being our psychology is
such that we connect to people before
anything it's called like a uh you know
self to self connection right or self to
world connection you need to connect to
someone it's very important it's in our
psychology but sometimes that's other
things are ignored and we prioritize
that connection at the expense of okay
what does this person represent or what
is the truth and so on and so forth
that's the challenge of humanity is to
go beyond the person the liking the
attachment and to look at truth and I
think I think most people that's why
they cannot Embrace Islam they cannot of
course Allah guides they cannot see the
truth is
because they are they're stopped by some
Allegiance some connection
some for lack of better worlds tribalism
Association my culture you know my
family my ethnicity there certain
ethnicity so strong BR the culture that
no way they can think about becoming
Muslim wow and that comes against even
God to them no doubt no doubt and
they'll tell you look I can't right like
there's no way like there's I'm not
going to name certain cultures but I
know these cultures very well and
they're just like the people be like no
way man like it's impossible for me to
become
Muslim my parents would kill me right
stuff like that not just that it's like
it's almost like an insult to themselves
their own ego and the schema they had
internally of who they are I represent
what I stand for even though I
acknowledge Islam as the truth but
because I come from like this Empire
that has thousands of years of History
this will be like the most embarrassing
thing that I could do you know what I
mean and just looking at the situation
right now Ina bro you know we we were
talking to omaran about this that men
today unfortunately are having bigger
crisis watching what's happening
inza living in the West in our
comfortable lives than the Men actually
that are dying and that are Just sh so
what advice would you have for men
nowadays to wake up why and before we
even get into that why do you think men
have become very soft today and
especially as men we're supposed to beam
right but we're just weak and feminine
as you
said okay U just to wrap up with Andrew
I just hope that the brother you know
understands what we're talking about I
hope that I mean of course we love yeah
we pray to Allah that um you know he
guides him and he you know Rectify
switch a few things change a few things
select his language a bit better better
use of words maybe in terms of certain
things and and that's it I think and
he's he's improved a lot I've noticed he
doesn't cuss anymore he doesn't he he
stopped drinking completely day one you
know even recently we've seen brother
sneo he went to with far andab the
Warner and you're just noticing the
change ASAP you know me and even inne
yeah for sure change subh definitely I
would say with with sneak was is a big
Improvement you know huge Improvement
alhamdulillah and with Andrew man even
like I want to say his last interview
with Pierce Morgan absolutely was just
really good one dominant was really
amazing alhamdulillah Islam wasn't
revealed in a day so no doubt it's gonna
take time but we got Allah may Allah any
help insh mean with regards to your
question look uh the way I want to frame
it is is this men have to understand now
we were sitting here outside and looking
and feeling
bad
and question is what if it comes home
what if the chickens come home to roost
right what if it happens to us what if
any day someone decides that we're you
know these Muslims these muslamic these
islamics they're not good for whatever
place you live in and you know you say
what if yet look at the six-year-old boy
in Chicago look at the hijabi sister in
Texas it's already happening look uh not
even that not long ago um this was a
reality um
for Southeast Asians Japanese uh in
Canada and USA the natives you know this
is history was there not too long ago
you know these con concentration camps
right then you have of course uh you
know the the Jews in the world war right
and so on uh with Nazism and all that
right you have a bunch of examples where
people are doing this right so you got
to be you got to understand that don't
don't feel that okay we live in this
democracy and this Freedom today and
people are very relaxed that's why
they're weak because back in the days
let's say we go hundred years back your
grandfather had twice as much as your
testosterone 50 while you had at 25 you
know big difference because the
lifestyle was different it required them
to be strong to be stoic it was just now
we live in a Uber Eats lifestyle driveth
through Chicken in insta everything
right so it's a very easy life for us
anywhere in the west of course there's
people in certain countries still really
really you know called like they call
third world countries which are still
struggling walking barefoot no resources
but that's
because anyway I don't want want to get
into that as to why those places have no
resources when they used to have a lot
of resources it's been stolen from them
for hundreds of years but hey let's uh
go back you know to our topic so yeah it
was it was a different lifestyle so
right now in the west people complain
about a hard life depression we're
having hard life it's so difficult it's
so easy man everything is at the tip of
your fingers we are so weak we are so
soft and we're complaining about
everything we're always depressed why
are you depressed I don't know no I
don't feel good why you said I don't
know wait a second so you have
everything in the tip of your fingers
even like some of the lowest class
people have access to Basics facilities
that could would be considered luxuries
in certain places in Africa or India
right be considered
luxurious and we're complaining not to
mention average middle class person
who's supposedly suffering from
depression it's usually middle upper
class people are suffering from
depression not you find the sorry for
lack of better worlds that the people
live on the street you find them being
happy sometimes saying hello and you
know other than maybe the druggies may
Allah you know guide them and that's
again another big reason as to why
they've reached that instead of the
government stopping that they keep using
taxpayers money to fund these clinics
and these save drugs and just a mess
so which leaves to the question do they
even want people to change or to you
know to become better but um we're weak
because our lifestyle is weak because we
are complaining all the time we've lost
our masculinity our hormones are all
over the place processed food processed
food women are stronger becoming
stronger now more
resilient more aggressive more masculine
there's so many changes in societ
Society they are one thing that I've
been studying recently and looking
really deeply into is how the female
psychology is changing due to the
environment and there's just so many
things that are apparent how they're
changing like literally they are
becoming men it's weird and their brain
is changing like literally the way their
brain is wired is changing like the the
neuros pychology behind this is just
fascinating to see how the neurop
pathways are changing and their behavior
is changing their cognition is changing
and men are becoming weaker I would say
and women are becoming stronger there's
a there's a shift there's a transition
there's still a lot more stronger men
physically but in a world that's not
that physical
anymore emotional strength and mental
strength is probably more important now
I'm not saying that we don't have to be
physical but kind of the world's been
set up on now on like emotions intellect
influence cerion right social media
influencer like who's making who is
influenc who's the
dominant energy and power
well women are are a big Pusher right
know and you can see it very clearly in
the world in the way fashion industry
uh purchasing power yeah and influence
like who influences sex cells and it's
all about the female Beauty their
Aesthetics and that just drives men left
and right isn't it it drives them insane
like guys are just they they're picking
themselves up from the ground you know
just wishing that a woman just gives
them a little bit of attention right
they pay for it they do anything for it
strip clubs only fans you name it guys
are hooked on this fitna of women and
women know that they can leverage that
power that seduction against men and men
are they used to be strong before or
they used to be like forget you I'm
going somewhere else I got options to
now like please give me one look please
give me one shout out on your only fans
chat or whatever right so that I can be
happy and go you know um pmo in peace
you
know there uh there was a guy who bought
some only fans models
bathwater yeah bathwater bro he paid
right I think 10 or 100,000 to get
shipped a little bottle of her her bath
water what this what a loser sorry the
sahaba died for this they died for men
to be who they are and come back to
Allah and this is what men are doing
this is where the energy shifts so again
they have like come on guy women are are
not going to go crazy over I don't think
any woman wants anyone's bath water any
male's bath water anyway no I don't
think so they have a that they have that
they just they don't like men that much
you know what I mean no honestly it's
just the way it
is a lot of them are just they swing
both ways now too even curious wise 100%
no not a lot of them all of them almost
I would say these days that's one thing
I've been studying a lot uh you know I
know people G to we can do another
episode on that we can do a definitely
another episode on fale that's only
going to be exclusive on our only fans
for sure
guys but this is the real deal but
Habibi why do you think that the men
today that even the ones that might
watch this video they might click on
another video Haram unfortunately
relapse after this or do you think it's
the lack of self-control do you think
that maybe if we lived in another
country like a Muslim country the
firewall it restricts a lot of different
websites what do you like what do you
think the problem is another Muslim
country firewalls will not restrict
anything the guys they always find a way
to get around the you know my students
were exper there was some guy that used
a VPN bro in the ham to relapse in the
ham and I'm just like you paid this much
to go to no uh it's again it's our
prefrontal cortex are destroyed they're
responsible for
impulses and a sexual urg an Impulse we
cannot control it this is the reality
women can control their sexual urges
much better than men that's why they
have they Dominate and they have the
strength when it comes to the the sexual
sphere right and that's why they can
swing men whichever way uh they want men
are weak these days when it comes to
this their impulses are very strong we
cannot resist it and we're so desperate
and therefore people are are basically
um doing all kinds of stuff um it's a
it's a crisis bro it is a
crisis we have to admit it admission is
the first thing then you have to work
towards it the problem is that it's not
so simple like a lot of guys talk online
and they're like yeah man you just have
to stop and be this strong person and
blah blah blah if you know the depth of
This Disaster you know that it's not so
because people have been addicted to
this for 20 years 15 years falling it's
a war it's a war and
um I I think it's a lot of it has to do
with the options that men have or don't
their sexual value is very weak women
don't I know it's going to sound weird
but and it's going to be contradictory
and not cont
controversial women
don't really they're made to think and
they're almost a lot of them are
convinced actually that they don't need
men if you think about it the way the
environment has been set programming
well it's well let me let me rephrase
that they don't need
husbands they need men okay so they need
a police officer obviously to defend
them right right but they that's a
resources a resource yeah they need a
mechanic he's a resour don't pay they
need a firefight
taxes and all that they'll pay yeah but
they don't so so protection now is taken
care of by police or firefighters or
military right so it's it's a resource
it was there but the husband used to be
the first line of defense he used to be
the guy for everything yeah for
everything for the car for mechanic but
now the husband can't change the tires
he cannot change the tires he cannot uh
fix a plug he cannot uh fix the plumbing
nothing he can't start a fire he can't
change a light bulb bro many people like
you know like I'm you know you cannot so
that's the reality like most guys like
how many guys have changed a tire how
many you know put a put a donut on how
many guys know how to checked the tire
pressure or check the oil or change the
oil or something like that most people
cannot know the plus and the minus on
the battery they don't have a toolbox
they you know they don't put a nail in
you know then on the wall to hang a
they'll pay someone see is is it a
surprise then that women have you know
rely on the police for protection they
rely on the mechanic for the car needs
they have a work husband they have the
guy who's creep in the DMS that sends
her venmo for gas money they have 15
guys that are just giving her what Once
Upon a Time only one man does she even
need guys though that's the thing right
so she she can they have uh sex toys for
pleasure which what about for
procreation for procreation they can be
em they can be in children actually the
way the world has been structured is to
eliminate the need of a husband you
cannot eliminate the need of a man
because you have to call men to do the
Dirty Jobs you know the gutter jobs the
high power and you know high dimension
jobs and all those have to be done by
men no doubt but uh women don't need a
husband they they can just live together
right they can uh there's there's toys
to please they don't need love they got
romance novels they got romance novels
they can even as I said you know they
can love each other they fall in love
with each other it's something that
women are easier to do you know men
don't really do that it's not that easy
uh so yeah it's uh it's crazy how the
world's
been MoneyWise the government will
sponsor and take care of them if they
really need to much easier than a man
child custody custody is
disproportionate alimony settlements
everything Alon settlements and we were
actually talking about this with uh one
of my friends who was backstage that
many brothers Unfortunately they when
they get legally married guys understand
we're not here to tell you to you know
go against the law of your land we're
not telling you not to do that either
but we're not telling you to not get
legally married but the ones that do
unfortunately sometimes women use these
man-made governmental laws over the laws
of Allah they will exploit the man and
they really don't think that they're
going to have to account for every
dollar that they take unjustly on the
day of judgment they really don't think
that that's coming so at the end of the
day many men are in this situation so we
have gotten the short end of the stick
would don't you say in society 100% but
we also can't complain and whine about
it we can't be a victim We're Men We
Can't be victims about it so what do you
think men do when they start figuring
these things out we can't just you know
be redpilled and now start watching all
these black pill videos start being
nihilistic so what do we
do yeah we cannot do that because we are
we're Muslim so we're hold accountable
we're held accountable to a certain
standard so you're kind of between a
rock and a hard place so you have to
obey Allah at the same time you cannot
fight the system the way you would want
to with this like you cannot Fight Fire
with Fire um so men have to really just
work on themselves just go back to the
Quran Sunnah realign themselves with the
objective that Allah has created for us
and just literally whenever you lost man
just find yourself back to Allah and
work on yourself just realize your
weaknesses stop denying it stop calling
someone else we're all in that situation
there no everyone yeah people flexing
left and right but don't be deceived by
what you see okay a lot of people live
their lives through the lenses of other
people to their social media accounts of
other people don't fantasize that you're
I don't know who and what okay even
these
people honestly as a as a student of
psychology when I look at their talks
and so on you can tell that they've been
through a lot or they're going through a
lot lot and the you know there's a
deception in the front everyone puts the
best front when they're online don't and
and a lot of people will look at that
and then they're comparing themselves to
them and go even lower it's like I'm not
like that or look at this person wow wow
wow wow wow I'm so bad I'm so weak I'm
so this I'm so that just look for
inspiration always look for positives if
you see someone that's doing better than
you be happy for them and try to do
better yourself don't look at it as like
oh I'm down and they're up look at him
I'm up and I want to get or they're up
and I want to go up there as well you
know because isn't it part of the sun to
want for your brother what you want for
yourself none of you truly believe until
that right yeah we don't be jealous man
don't be jealous if someone does well be
thankful alhamdulillah thank Allah subh
you know Allah will give you you know
the same in Allah can give everyone the
same and it won't take away from his
Dominion so don't have this weak mindset
have a big mindset think big you'll
become big and if not this is your you
know you cannot fight in the end what's
destined for you if Allah decides to
change it from your Dua or from your
good deeds that's up to Allah you don't
know what's going to happen just enjoy
the ride and do your best and that's it
yeah absolutely bro and like men that
I've seen that are obsessed with
scarcity they're usually men that they
make the thing that they're attributing
scarcity to they're God even if it's not
uppercase G it's still something that
they it's an IL it's something that they
worship it's something that it's the
center of their universe and when that's
something many times Allah will not give
you that because you're failing the test
of putting Allah in the center of the
universe and and Allah should be your
mental point of origin for everything
else and when you put that one thing
whether it's money it's women it's lust
it's desires whether it's a substance
you're consumed by you're no longer
learning that this is might just be a
test or a resource or a means to jna
like you know it's not the end it
consumes no doubt and I think for men
today we know what it is it's it's women
you know I mean it's not money people
think it's money it's not money guys
guys don't want to I'm talking to young
men they're don't they're not hungry to
make money they don't care I'm like dude
at your age I was working two jobs I was
pulling in like 2K a month at the age of
14 you know and when bro back then was a
lot it was a lot 2K was a lot I was 6K I
was working midnights bro on the weekend
and you know Fords and GM and these you
know uh you did sales or what no man on
the line Parts SC
Parts you know they call you in for like
where people Miss shifts people calling
sick you just got to show up within half
an hour they call you like 11 at night
you know you got you're the benchwarmer
benchwarmer right but you make crazy
money though and I was but these guys
are not motivated so I'm like what do
you guys want you don't want money you
don't want uh to achieve something
people are going to say oh brother you
want people this is part of I'm not
saying to have it in your heart I'm not
saying to be chasing it only but human
beings are driven to an extent by
resources if your right intention is
there why you having these resources
that's makes it a whole big difference
right but these guys don't want to they
just want they're just obsessed with
women women women women girl you know
just atten of a girl I'm in love I miss
my heart blah blah they don't want
nothing else except
women godamn background no why do you
want to make money oh to get married why
do you want to get in the gym and get
your body right oh to attract the girl
it's always for a woman yeah and let's
be honest using women as a motivator is
not a bad thing because at the end of
the day it keeps you going right but
what are you gonna do then when you get
married are you going to stop working
out are you going to stop making money
you need something that is beyond that
like something doing it for the sake of
Allah doing it for some actual motive
not just something superficial like
women bro and this is why I believe that
today we live in a pandemic where once
men can overcome that even though it's
difficult it's almost like women can
sense that on you when they know that
they can't just woo you with their Abaya
so to be Suave they can't just look a
certain way and they'll have you wrapped
around their fingertips and when women
sense that there's something alluring
about that there's something intriguing
about that they sense
raw I guess you could say outcome deep
outcome independent detached raw
masculinity that energy has not been you
know tapped into by most men today it's
it's attractive it's attractive women
resonate to that and that's why women
are not very attracted to most men today
is because they're these guys are so
needy and this neediness is not
something that they find attractive in a
men
whatsoever no way so and you actually
are doing something about this right you
have a community where men can kind of
work together gang together and overcome
these things and become a Muslim Alpha
almost right so tell us a little bit
about that yeah the Muslim Alpha men
course is basically to help men change
their mindset and reprogram their heads
according to the Quran Sunnah prioritize
Allah then prioritize their
self-development and by default the
outcome of this will be all those things
that they're chasing now but those are
just going to be outcomes of you
prioritizing Allah prioritizing yourself
developing yourself working on yourself
change your mindset even if you don't
have all these resources it doesn't
matter you can you can be from anywhere
anywhere in the world as long as you
know it's sunny in your head and you
have a good mindset and good Iman you
can do a lot of things man a lot of
things so this course teaches that and
alhamdulillah many people have changed
their lives yeah I've seen some of the
testimonials man it's it's an amazing
work and this is not because this is
like some like you know Manis feere
podcast he selftaught you have actual
academic clinical experience right so
what are some of your like academic
background yeah so alhamdulillah I've uh
studied biology and psychology
neuroscience and cognition which kind of
focused on how does
cognition influence behavior right how
the way we understand the way our brain
works and how does that influence
um our Behavior oh sub Allah yeah so
that's you know Islamic Studies
alhamdulillah as well and
counseling and positive psychology so
I've I've always been a student of of
you psychology and try to understand not
only the mind the soul and it's a
lifelong process just a
student H but it's it's amazing it's
fascinating some of the things that you
learn and
how
the the fitra right because I think it's
a study of the F how amazing it is and
how it
proves
Islam you know people always say prove
Islam prove Islam the Islam is the true
thing I'm like look in your
s in yourself you find the signs right
Allah tells us to see in oursel really
when you look at your Humanity you
cannot deny Islam it's impossible Subhan
Allah yeah this being said right now
fortunately we got to wrap up we have an
event to go to what's what's the event
we got a conference yeah we got a
conference aim conference alhamdulillah
And discussing the issues surrounding
what's happening in Gaza in Palestine
hopefully it's going to be a very very
productive one inah inshah now last
thing but definitely not the least where
can men find you yeah if you just type
gabri
aromani in Google you'll find my
Instagram my YouTube you got Tik Tok or
you got banned I got banned I got
deleted but I started someone started a
new one for me I forgot what we I think
we got banned 150k or something I don't
know but it was we made a video the Tik
Tok Community is just very very weak and
they just report you for like the
smallest but you know what you'll post
there's a woman it's literally called
the no end November I'm not going to say
what it is but her account on Tik Tok
was strictly dedicated to being the no
end November relapser so she would make
videos obviously 60 seconds trying to
get you to relapse I kid you not out
there promoted by the algor yet we will
post the most wholesome Pious content to
fortify your Islam and
getan Broan is a is a good way of
working but more test more FNA more
reward right inshallah that's what it is
man we make Dua for that we know which
what's the biggest F the prophet told us
women that's just the way it is man
absolutely you like it or not
alhamdulillah Subhan Allah uh brothers
and sisters is Ja for tuning in if you
haven't caught our episodes with Gabriel
alomani if you haven't caught our
episodes with him we did a lot of
episodes you know some crazy genin
stories intimacy series he's known as
the king of intimacy in uh this side of
YouTube unfortunately or fortunately
depending on how you look at it and
please tune in make sure you subscribe
to his channel gonna be the exclusive on
H female sexuality yes this is gonna be
the big one the big cancel us or yes
we're gonna be inshallah if you guys you
can't hate us for the truth you know
unfortunately this is what other du are
talking about intimacy like this when
you look at the prophet he was very open
with the shabab when you look at the
they were not shy about these topics so
they shouldn't be respectful but open
right so inallah we'll bring you guys
that transparency um stay tuned for a
lot of episodes coming up inshallah we
got part two with the sorial shooter
coming up soon got a podcast with Tam KH
all of these they're all filmed by the
way guys we just need to get on the
editing inshallah
um if we have not found any editors by
then guys if you know how to edit proper
videos please hit us up inshallah start
working for us we are hiring more
editors on the team and this being said
it's been a pleasure bro may Allah bless
you immensely and uh with that being
said any final
words accept and help
[Music]
us